Okay. Hopefully you picked dish soap. We're going to add just a squeeze of
this here, into the water. We're going to
take some of the meat tenderizer. We're
going to add that too. Just a sprinkling of it. Now what I'm going to
do, is I'm going to take my fork, and I'm actually going to start mashing up.
[SOUND].
And what you want to do is mash the strawberries
up really well, and you want to mix it up.
[SOUND].
And what you're doing is breaking down the strawberry
tissue, at the same time you're helping rice the
cells open, break them open, with the soap and
the meat tenderizer. Now, we're going to add one other ingredient
right now. We're going to add the salt. The salt's
going to come into play later when we need to precipitate
DNA. It turns out DNA has a charge to
it. And it wants to stay in solution with water.
But if we add a little salt when we get to
precipitation step of alcohol. It'll come out a solution a lot
easier. So you want to add just a little bit of
salt, maybe a teaspoon, and then we're going to mix it
all up again. Continually mashing to break up big chunks of
tissue, and hopefully our soap and our meat tenderizer will do
the rest. Okay, so once you've got it nice and mixed
you'll remember that our second step is that we want to break
down the protein. And our meat tenderizer's going to do
that in the warm water, but we need to
give it time to work. So what I want to
do is, we want to set the timer for about
[SOUND]
three minutes. And while the timer's going, we're
going to keep mashing, and keep swirling. Okay, it's been three
minutes. Mm. Smells kind of good. If you had
to guess, what do you think it smells like?